coming up on 6 26 on your monday morning  well we are starting week two of the new  school year with a big time what were  you thinking moment in a ccsd school  zone this is from last friday  metro police social media posting a car  taken off our streets after going nearly  quadruple the school zone speed limit  saying  when the lights are flashing it's not a  suggestion if you choose to drive 97 in  a 25 mile an hour school zone you  choose a ride to the clark county  detention center  wow okay nobody was hurt in this  situation but the social media post does  point out that seven pedestrians died on  our roads just last week buckle up drive  carefully pay attention to the school  zones and put down that phone you can  join the driving crazy conversation at  traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com